each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
um it's a real pleasure for me to
welcome back to Microsoft chemin chen
who was previously i guess was two years
ago an intern with us on the on the
Phoenix project that work turned out to
be very successful and we ended up just
lost your display there ended up
publishing a paper in ic de on how to
optimize recovery for Phoenix components
the chemin was a microsoft holder of
microsoft fellowship as well and did a
crackerjack job for us then I followed
Shannon's work for a while and I can
tell you that that he's doing some of
the more interesting work in terms of of
having systems but I keep talking I me
not how long I need to talk you're back
oh okay he's been he's been working in
the area of how to adapt database
systems to thee to the problems of the
newer architectures where memory delays
are very long compared with cpu cycle
times and as most of you know who were
attended the ICD II conference even IBM
seems to have gotten that message and as
part of part of one of the challenges
that Pat Selinger indicated for the for
the next decade so so Sherman's a bit
ahead of the curve on this ms area and
he's going to tell us about about his
work in this area today thank you I
think a lot of people here actually
quite familiar with severe cache
performance so today I'm going to talk
about rethinking database system designs
for exploiting modern computer
architecture features so most commercial
database systems today we're actually
implemented in the 1980s and in a
computer system of 1980s the main memory
was quite close to the CPU while a disk
was very far away from the main memory
so the main memory access latency was
roughly the time to execute an
instruction well this consents costs on
the order of the 10 to the 5th memory
accesses and moreover the memory size
was small therefore hard data of the
database was primarily on disk and the
database systems use main memory as the
cash for disk and build our pool
structures in main memory data pages
need to be first read from disk to main
memory before being processed and the
disk to memory gap is the traditional
focus of database studies today this
picture changes although the disk to
memory gap does not change much the
memory access is very costly now so
several decades of the database studies
have proposed a lot of io optimizations
and these optimizations have been
implemented in the database system today
and more were the solar systems today
has large main memories from several
gigabyte to even a terabyte so more and
more hard data can now stay in the in
the main memory and this is the only one
more shoe with the capacity of the
memory increasing so business system
today can tolerate the disk to memory
gap better on the other hand several
performance studies on commercial
database systems pointed out that over
fifty percent of the execution time in
memory is often wasted due to cache
misses and the memory to cash gap is
becoming the major performance problem
so let's look at the company
architecture trend to understand the
significance of this problem so this
Steiger plots the memory access latency
versus instruction execution time over
the years the y-axis is in log scale so
in the year nineteen eighty our backs
Elevens than 80 machine the memory
access latency
was less than a time to execute an
instruction however today a memorex s
can easily cause hundreds of
interstellar cycles and considering the
widest rate of the modern processors a
memory access can cost over a thousand
instruction execution opportunities
today and this gap between main memory
and CPU is widening exponentially at the
first glance the disk to memory gap and
the memory to cash gap look very similar
so we are using the main memory as a
cash for bisque and we're using the
hardware CPU cache as a cash for the
main memory however they're actually
very different we have very different
capacities block sciences and Layton
sees for example disk blocks are 42 64
kilobytes large while cache lines are
only 32 to 128 bytes min memory buffers
are really fully associative well there
are some limited set of such activities
for the CPU caches memory buffers are
usually managed by software while cpu
caches are managed by hardware so it is
more difficult for program software's to
control the CPU cache and the bandwidth
of sharing properties are different so I
low bandwidth is shared across all the
processes and threads in the operating
system no matter that rat is running or
blocking however the main memory
bandwidth is only used by threats
actually running on a cpus and if the
threat if the boundaries is not used it
is simply wasted because of these
differences we have to reconsider the
solutions for this to memory gap in the
new contacts and in many cases we need
to come up with new solutions there are
two general approaches to improving the
CPU cache performance of a piece of code
locality organizations reduce the number
of cache misses and prefetching reduce
the exposed miss latency of cache misses
for example
we can improve the CPU cache performance
of matrix multiplication by using a
locality optimization technique called
blocking the basic idea is to compute
the matrix multiplications who blocked
matrix multiplication and make sure the
block sizes are small so that all the
Attic blocks can be kept in the CPU
cache in this way we reduce the number
of cache misses by improving the reuse
the data reuse within every block
however locality organizations cannot
remove all cache misses therefore we use
cash profession techniques to hide miss
latency for all the remaining cache
misses so modern processors support our
non blocking caches and this means
multiple cache misses can be serviced
simultaneously in the cache hierarchy
and modern processors support prefetch
assembly instructions so that we can
insert these protections in our code to
influence the timing of the cache misses
for example a piece of code here incurs
to cache misses because of to load
instructions if we know the load address
is early enough we can issue pre fetches
early and load data into the cache
before the actual execution of the
instructions in this way we overlap
cache misses with computation and we
also we all have cache misses we with
other cache misses so this is because
the the memory system cancer is multiple
cache misses simultaneously catch
prefetching has been shown to be
effective on scientific and engineering
code but it has not been well studied in
database systems before before I exploit
cash prefetching for database systems I
focus on interviewing non-contiguous
access patterns because sequential
classes to make arrays has been well
studied before I focus on important
database structure stomp on the
operations so typically index structure
and join operation so in the rest of the
talk I will mainly focus on redesigning
index structures and then I will briefly
describe my ideas
on the joint operations I would describe
brilliant work and conclude with future
plans so in that structures are used
extensively in databases for fast
associative lookups for example given
the phonebook sorted by the name we want
to find out the name and address
information for particular phone number
the brute force way is just to scan the
whole phonebook checking every phone
record however a much better way is to
use the index if we have an index on a
phone number we can directly retrieve
the phone record by using the phone
number a calming index implantation in
databases is because restructure so
compared to another fight the the
familia binary structure the beetle tree
is just an own way search tree and n is
a much larger than too literally so for
example to minimize the number of disk
accesses the traditional people in don't
size is the disk page typically for to
64 kilobyte large so people tree is a
balance the tree structure or the leaf
nodes occur at the same level a leaf
contains a solid icky array and their
corresponding pointers to the records in
database table and the leaf also
contains a sibling pointer and the
sibling pointer connects all the leaf
nodes in key order all the non leaf
parts of the people are sure you are
built of for the indexing purpose only
anomic node contains a key array and
appoint these the pointers to sub trees
for example all the keys in step 20 are
less than key one and all the trees all
the keys r sub 31 are less than keep a
greater than or equal to key one but
less than key to so a search in the b+
tree starts at from the root node here
we do a binary search in the key array
and to determine the child pointers to
follow we then follow the trail pointer
to get down one level we perform binary
search and follow child pointers at
every level of the tree and you we get
down to the leaf level here we do
another binary search and receive the
record pointer to the record
in the database table so there are two
common access patterns in p + Chee the
first is the search lack operation
including insertions and deletions and
insertions deletions begin with a search
followed by some data movements for the
updates the other common access pattern
is a range scale operation which is to
locate a collection of records within a
key range for example the phone company
can find out all the customers within
the local area code by issuing a range
scan with the beguine range as four and
20 000 and the end ring as the 129 99 a
99 to do a range scan we first search
for the begin key and then we follow the
leaf linked list of sibling pointers to
retrieve the record pointers and you we
encounter the end key you can see that
the search is following a pointer from
root to leaf node while a rich gang is
following the linked list of leaf nodes
so I take two steps for redesigning p+
trees first I focus on a pure main
memory environment and exploit cash
prefetching in this environment for ps3
and then I consider the entire memory
hierarchy taking disk i/o performance
into the picture so to minimize the
number of data transfers we can compute
that the optimal of bills is the natural
data transfer size for disk this is a
disk page size which is typically for 2
64 kilobyte large for cash this is a
cache line size typically three to two
hundred twenty eight bytes large so
compared to a people actually optimized
for disc OB paltry optimized for cash
has much narrower nodes and is much
higher therefore its performance is more
sensitive to the changes in
lounging factors so previous work I'll
catch sensitive people are trees and try
to increase the fell out of a tree node
by restricting data layout so the basic
idea is to lay out the child node of a
single parent of the same time parent
contiguously in main memory in this way
we only need to keep the pointer to the
first child in the parent and the
locations of all the other children can
be computed from the first pointer this
essentially eliminates all but one child
pointer in olin on leaf nodes and if the
pointer size and the keys eyes are same
this effectively doubles the bounding
factor of cache line size non-leaf nodes
so in this figure I show two sets of
experiments a search experiment a
deranged gang experiment the y-axis
reports execution time normalized to be
close trees with one cache line size the
note so each bar is broken down into
three categories the bottom blue part is
the beauty time in the CPU is busy
executing instructions the top red part
is data cache souls the processor cannot
make forward progress because of a data
cache miss and the middle growing parts
are other stores for example because of
resource constraint so we can see that
most execution time is wasted on data
cache loss this is even true for the
caster's of the people three kids and
compared to people through the constants
rupee per tree and has passed the surges
is mainly due to the reduction in height
of the tree however update performance
of CSP parse tree is actually worse that
becomes free because because because it
wants to keep the canoes layout of the
children and it does not improve the
brainstem performance so there's no
significant room for improvement so my
solution is to exploit cash prefetching
to reduce the amount of exposed miss
latency and the key challenge here
it's deepa dependencies caused by
chasing pointers I was sure that my
solution can achieve significant
performance gains for searches brain
scans and unifor updates and I'll show
that my scheme is complementary to the
CSP paltry scheme so let's look at a
search in a people a tree with non size
equals to 1 cache line so if there are
1000 keys and the cache line is 64 byte
and we have 4 byte keys and pointers
there will be four levels in the
bloodstream a search will cause on full
cash means at each level of the tree if
a cache means is working the 50 cycle a
search will cost six hundred cycles in
total if we increase the note width from
one page 92 to cache lines the height of
the tree that is either going to be
reduced to three levels however now we
incur to cache misses at every level of
the tree and this additional cash means
per node dominates the reduction in a
number of levels and we actually get
worse performance however things will
change if we can exploit cash
prefetching if we prefetch all the lines
within a node in parallel then the two
cache misses of a cache of a node will
go out in parallel and be serviced
simultaneously in the memory system and
the exposed miss latency of the second
cache miss will be much smaller than the
full cache miss latency so my solution
for prefetching for search is just to
make notes wider than the natural data
transfer size and prestretch all cache
lines of a note before searching in a
note search performance is improved
because of the larger bounding factors
and shallower trees and at the same time
the cost to access every node is only
increased slightly so we can use this
formula to compute the optimal node with
so but trying to access the note is
equal to mmm a full cache miss latency
to load the first cache line and then
expose miss agency to know the rest of
rest of the cache lines and the search
time is equal to a time to access a node
multiplied by the tree height where tree
height here is a function of the node
bits so this whole thing is a function
of note bits before we can and choose
the note with to minimize the search
time to be the optimal bits so let's
switch to a c-ring second cache behavior
on a people tree with one cache line
size note here we incur a fool Kashmir's
for each leaf node yes I guess my first
question is this assumes that there's a
spare bandwidth for the cache memory yes
um so yes that's right so if the balance
is not used it will be wasted the main
memory bandwidth can only be used by the
threats actually running on processors
and we have to actually can see so I
have done some experiments with my wife
join our zone later all right into
machine I'll show you that actually
there are plenty of bandwidth so
I guess I haven't seen
we're seeing service understand the case
where we have excess cash bandwidth
it was a it's 32 Park machine you have
32 processors that are asking for memory
right and one individual one of them may
not be using anything at the time but
there's other ones that are so the net
effect is that
our first dominated by the number of l3
mrs. for whatever this is not and
there's no extra have so so basically
here what I'm trying to do is to overlap
the cache misses and try to utilize the
parallelism of the memory system and you
can think of the memory system as a
queue right so each cache miss will be
serviced so basically entered into the
queue and we service in the first thing
for salt order something like that so by
using a profession we actively insert
the elements into the kill right so if
you are not using the profession even
you are using three to four sensors in
the system if you are only just
inserting in Tokyo sporadically
so actually I sorry so so okay so f and
also first thing memory panelists is
very important is the scare scarce
resource however it's so even in the
Molly predator system it is not a shared
shared past based multi-party system so
the man they actually the processor may
not share the same manner bad bills so
it is a like just Numa based basically
so like you have different classes of
machines sharing the same local memory
and then you have links to visit the
remote memory it's possible that only
the cluster sharing the local memory
they have they share the same manner
bandits well across you you're sharing
you're not sharing the same manner but
memory bandwidth and also I think also
for supplying prefetching technique is a
second step if the first step is really
you try to reduce the number of cache
misses and then for those cache misses
that you can't reduce you apply cash
prefetching okay
yes so are you are you adding to the
memory bandwidth requirements I mean
northeast fetches that you have to make
anyway we just know I mean if you get
halfway through the array you don't you
find the child that you want you don't
have to have that second page right it's
like a cache line so
on average you're probably adding
my conclusion is you are assuming that
there is is cache memory bandwidth
available what is to work okay and in
some cases there may be so much kisses
help yes
that's like okay yes so do you organize
some reason not within that each node
within each internal node of the CSV
frustrates you have multiple Cashman's
but do you restore the key is
contiguously so you have to wait for all
the cash night to be loaded then you can
perform the binary search or you do it
some kind of reorganize the video the
key is a little bit so you can perform
some search when you load the first
cache line and you don't have any if you
found any solutions you can avoid to
notification ok so I think the second
case because I'm only issuing professors
and then I will go into the loop to do
to the search if the so it just depends
on the processor it wait for the cash
cash means to finish but as all as soon
as the first cache miss finishes it will
go ahead to do the search the key
comparisons or the change in search
algorithm at all no just making shrine
Italian it by the research that's what
you do yes that's right so you are using
a binary search here that's right so so
binary search would of course relax I
can touch differently that's right so
maybe you can so did you order you your
issue the professor's can be happy tune
maybe you can issue the prefetch to the
middle of the touchline
so yes so we incur Fukushima's for
eronel leaf nodes accessed in the range
scan if we apply the prefetching wider
nose idea here we achieve better
performance this is a definite
improvement but how is you do better so
we want to / app cache misses and you
all latency is hidden or we run out of
bandwidth to achieve something like this
but how can we achieve this basically if
you represent a leaf node with a yellow
rectangle here we want to overlap the
cache misses across leave note the
question is how do we to achieve this
okay so for example we're currently
visiting the Blue Note and we want to
prefetch three nodes ahead we want to
refer to the red node and naive
implementation is to issue a prefetch
instruction like this by using the
sibling pointers however this won't work
this is because the ceiling pointer to
the next node is stored in the previous
node and the processor must finish
reading the previous node in order to
get the address to eat to issue the
prefetch for the next node therefore
this approach will still experience the
full latency at every node but we want
is really to directly prefetch three
nodes ahead so my solution here is to
put leaf node addresses into an array
conceptually and in this way we can use
this array to prefetch three nodes ahead
directly and we call this array a jump
point array and to initiate prefetching
we also need pointers from the leaf
nodes back to the location in the jump
point array and then a jump on the rate
prefetching goes on like this after
searching for the begin key we follow
the follow the back pointer to the
location in the jump point array and
then we use you two more professors from
that
we visit a note and prefetch three knows
ahead and here we encounter the end key
no not here the prefetch actually goes
beyond the end range but if the grain
size is large this overshooting cost is
minimum so here I prefetch three nodes
ahead and this is the two more parameter
called prefetching distance so we want
to make the profession distance large
enough to hide all cache miss latency
therefore if the memory latency is
larger the preventing distance will be
larger and actually in this conceptual
array organization we can prefetch
arbitrarily far head however the update
cost of this conceptual array is huge we
not only pay the cost of data movement
within the array if we do insertion but
also we need to change the back pointers
from the leaf node julia rae so the
applicants is huge to improve the
conceptual array design i make three
improvements first I break the array
into a chant linked list and to limit
the impact of the insertion to his own
jack and then I actively interleave
empty slots in a chunk on while I build
the array and while I split the chunk so
that insertion will find an empty slot
close to reduce the data movement and
third I change the meaning of the back
pointers from a precise pointer to an
approximate pointer so its dew points to
the correct chunk however within a chanc
the location is approximate in this way
i have avoid updating the back pointers
but it may require local searches within
the channel to initiate prefetching but
in practice this this part of the cost
is very small so actually looking at the
people she struck structure they are
existing structures in people tree that
contain leave no doubt dresses these are
the parents of the leaf nodes if we link
the parents of lead notes together we
can use them as a jump point array
and we call this implementation an
internal jump on array so compared to
the previous external 10-point array an
internal array is simply to implement
because most of the maintenance work is
taken care of but by the B+ recode and
it also consumes less space although the
previous external array already it has
very low / space / head however internal
jump point array is less flexible
because the chunk size here is fixed by
people tree structure and when the
memory agency is very large it may not
be possible to fully hide the cash mr.
agency because you cannot issue prefetch
arbitrary far away but but I didn't
didn't see this effect in my experiments
so my experiments I assume yes leave
sighs they turn a low tides could be
smaller than with a large leaf size then
is indirect equal into having these
things can give us and memory then you
don't need any of the jump a raise yes
but you also change the structure of the
betray taking a common presentation you
fix it sighs
virtual more so here I'm talking about
memory main memory development so he'll
adult sizes is like a few cache lines
are probably really it's going to be on
this solution I would talk about this
later a second question
so I assume in my experiment i assume
pure main memory environment and I
insert profession structions in to see
source code by using GCC unite
assemblies so the government's
measurement is performance is measured
through detailed cycle accurate
simulations and the machine model is
based on a compact he has come back of a
server cs30 system which has advanced
memory hierarchy so for the search
performance our x-axis I vary the number
of keys in the tree from 10,000 to 10
million and I perform 100,000 random
searches I report the time execution
time you million cycles on y-axis so
this first line is the pecan street
performance the peepal tree is one cache
line size note this is the salespeople
tree with a one cache line size note
this is the prefetching people tree with
the optimal note size eight cache lines
and you can see that the professional
approach tree achieves significantly
better performance over people's tree
and over csv paltry if we combine the
prefetching wider nose idea and the
sespe policy idea together we actually
achieve even better performance this
means that prefetching wider nose idea
and the six people are three idea
actually complimentary so in the code
cache performance I perform the same set
of experiment but flash cpu caches in a
simulator before every search and you
can clearly see the step light pattern
for every curve and these steps
correspond to the changes in the number
of levels in the tree for example let's
focus on the b blood stream curve which
the top curve you can see that the
number of levels are five six 6 seven 7
eight 8 so clearly the height of the
tree dominates the performance and this
effect is blurred in the previous one
cache case so for instance formance
accesses are very the key rindge size
from
thankies to a meeting keys and y-axis I
report execution time in log scale so
this is the people's trees with pankaj
lines last note and this is a profession
wider nose idea external jump on your I
prefetching and internal temp pointer
air prefetching you can see that the two
temporary implantation actually achieve
very similar performance focusing on the
key ranges that have a larger number of
keys click them of 1000 and more keys we
can see that providing wider nose idea
give us over three-fold speed up while
jump point Henry prefetching give us an
additional two fold speed up and
achieving a total over six foot speed
apps over the baseline people tree and
focusing on a smaller range you can see
the old shooting cost is noticeable that
means more we should exploit jump on
Terry prefetching only if the range is
expected to be large or alternatively we
should search for the unlived no.2 and
use that as a collision to start the
profession to avoid overfitting cost so
my experiment actually observe that
insertion performance of the profession
people tree is better than the baseline
people's free with one hydrolyzed node
and this is because of two reasons when
the tree is not very full and insertions
can find empty slots in leaf nodes um
the incision time is dominated by search
time therefore faster searches lead to
faster insertions however one trees are
very full almost every insertion these
two a costly note splits we actually
observe that with wider nose there are
fewer notes bits because of this
so returning to the cash flow from is
great down and add the profession people
strip bars you can see that for search
be eliminated about forty five percent
of the original data cap stores and for
strange scan will even a naked about
ninety seven percent of the original
data cache stores so in summary I
proposed normal profession techniques
for search and range scan and the
solution without seen faster searches
updates and green scans and the
technique is complementary to assess me
Patrice yes you know experiment they use
simulators so how many in-flight cash
basis can can can be served the same
time 22
so only yes 40 machine the memory system
kind of support 24 in fact as mrs. so
it's a memory system it has 10 support
24 outstanding cache misses and the
processor actually support 32 in-flight
stores and 30 green light load
only serve option for outstanding yes
but but it's so I talked to my advisor
at heart Lori he's an architect he told
me that it's not very difficult to
increase the number of outstanding
entries this is just a buffer so you
just increase them a little bit hungry
resource so I guess my question we can
be related to that which is how
sensitive are your your results to the
particular hardware that your honor me
and you know an effort vac you go
running on a machine which had had more
limited capabilities and so first of all
I believe that the richest and
performance will always be better but
for the search performance you can
always compute the optimal nope it's
with some memory you can measure the
memory bandwidth and marry the memory
latency and computing know this may be
in some architecture the optimal size is
just one cache line so we just don't
just don't use more casual eyes
ok
okay so in a second step I consider the
whole memory hierarchy and this includes
the disk i/o performance in the picture
here are the problem is that a previous
research proposed to people trees for
disk performance and B plus freeze for
cache performance however because of the
large differences in note sizes these
proposals do not work very well in a
different context for example if a cache
opens people she cannot fit into main
memory then a search potentially fetch a
distinct this page for every node from
root to leaf because the tree is much
higher than this oppressed people tree
this is too many more these accesses and
discopolis people trees have very poor
cache performance many because of the
binary search in a large node so you can
think of a binary search in a large
array so you first visit the middle of
the ray and the quotient array so on so
forth the first several visits of the
large array tends to read a single did
item out of a whole cache line and throw
away the rest of the cache line so this
poor spatial locality incurs excessive
number of cache misses so because the
server has a today have large main
memories and it is possible that a whole
people she may stay in my memory and
also it is also possible that part of
the tree are still code and bears do on
disk therefore we are really looking for
a single index structure that can
optimize for both cash and disk
performance and the achieve good
performance in all these situations so
my approach is to embed cash optimize
the trees inside bit augments the trees
so I call on this approach tractor
profession be plus fees because the
self-similarity tree within the tree
nature of this structure and here the
major challenge is no thighs mismatch
problem basically this page
and cash optimize the notes eyes are
determined by Hardware parameters and
key sizes therefore ideally we want the
cash on these trees to fit nicely in
these pages but you're this is not true
so example a two-level tree may overflow
at this page or a two level three mates
significantly the underflow at this page
and adding one more level overflows the
disk page so I propose two solutions for
this problem in solution one I use
different sizes for non leave and leaf
nodes so basically if there's overflow I
shrink the knowledge size and if there's
the underflow I increase the knowledge
size intervene to I do not change the no
sizes but instead i put the overflowing
nose into new disk pages and let me
become the rules of new disk page so
conceptually the first solution build a
disk automatically first and then fit
cash opens trees in two different pages
by varying the known sizes so i call
this solution a disk for a solution and
in the second solution conceptually we
build a cash up mystery first and then
we try to interact gently group the
Cassiopaeans nose into disk pages so I
call this solution a cash first version
so our experiments show that both
schemes have very good CPU cache
performance however only the disk first
solution has good dis performance the
cash flow solution may incur some large
disk overhead so in general we only
recommend the disk first solution and
the cash flow solution can only be used
one there are large main memory and the
people tree can stay in main memory so
this is for search performance very nice
can we actually can employ jump point or
a profession for both CPU cache
performance and for IO performance
actually jump point worry I'll
prefetching has been implemented in the
unit I BM universal database so and for
a set of experiments that you switched
again too confident the level of entries
in the table
this team achieved over 2.5 for speed
apps on db2 so next I'm going to talk
about my ideas of improving joint
operations so joints are frequently used
in databases to connect two tables for
example a student table contains all the
student information and the take course
table contains the grades for students
taking courses and then generating
transcripts involves a joint operation
here join key is the student ID column
basically for every student record we
want to find all the kicker's records
having the same student ID an efficient
way to do to find matches is to use hash
table so first we can build a hash table
on a student table by hashing our
student ID and then for every record in
the take course table we have proved the
hash table to find the matches and this
is called the simple hi drawing hours
and we recall the two tables build table
and probe table because of their
different rows in the actual algorithm
so the single hydrogen algorithm has a
problem because of the random access
patterns inherent in hashing if the
build table and hash table cannot fit
into main memory it will incur excessive
random iOS to avoid random dis accesses
the Hydra algorithm actually use a
technique called IO partitioning the
idea is to first divide the input tables
in two partitions with the hash function
and then to impair the partitions
separately using a simple hi drawing
algorithm and another result oh and the
algorithm has situation I all patterns
for both the input tables and the
intermediate partitions and I show
yourself experiment that we've advanced
IO techniques such as IO prefetching and
with reasonable I'll bandwidths hash
join can be CPU bound therefore I only
focus on the CPU cache performance
of her joints so I also take two steps
for rethinking hash coins in my first
step I exploit cash prefetching for the
two phases separately and in the second
step I exploit this two phase structure
to generate some actual information from
IO partitioning phase that can greatly
helps the phase two of the areas so the
challenge of exploiting cash prefetching
in this context is that it's very
difficult to generate address early it
is very very difficult to predict
addresses because of the random of
randomness of hashing and also within
the processing of a record there are
data dependencies and these forms point
of tracing problems so but but the good
news is that we are processing a large
number of records and the dependencies
are rare across subsequent workers
because of the randomness of hashing
therefore we can take advantage of this
in turn record parallel ISM and prevent
across what jump to conclusion
okay so yeah so I prefetch across
multiple records and I propose two
schemes grew prefetching and software
pipeline prefetching these two schemes
are inspired by compiler scheduling
schemes however we can handle in
READ&WRITE convicts and other hash
drawing complexities correctly while
these complexities hinder the
application of the compiler techniques
the components cannot safely prove their
transformation so I want to use a
conceptual pictures to illustrate my
solutions so the processing of a record
can be broken down into several stages
are you stated to represent a different
code stage and use line segments to
represent different cache misses for
example on stage zero can be computing a
schmucky number from a joint attribute
and stage one can be visiting the hatch
packet header and this cache miss is the
cash means to read packet header
therefore on the state one cannot start
and cue the cache miss finishes
similarly stage two cannot start until
the second camp cache miss finishes song
so forth therefore the Sigma half
drawing algorithm has this cache
behavior there's absolutely no overlap
but cross the processing of subsequent
records he grew prefetching I rearranged
the processing of multiple records in a
group like this I first process the
coast h0 for all the records in the
group and then I issue prefetch is for
the cache misses for the first cache
misses old Oracle zone in the group and
these cash means we'll go out into main
memory in parallel and serviettes
simultaneously and then I percents con
stage one for all the records in the
group and issue pre fetches for the
second cache misses song so forth in
this way I can overlap cache misses a
crops the processing of multiple
records in a group here interestingly in
group prefetching I all will have cash
basis across the cache miss of the same
color which means the cash basis of the
same memory reference in software
pipeline prefetching we can achieve a
cache behavior like this here we all
have cache misses across different
memory references so I did experiments a
reason usually I did experiments on line
I canim to machine and show that my
schemes can achieve up to triple speed
ups for her joints I also did some
simulation study varying the memory
latency from 100 fitted cycles to 1,000
cycles so comparing the performance is
under different memory latency
conditions the absolute performances of
my solutions are very close that means
my solution you will be still effective
for memory latency in the near future
and a surprising piece of result in my
experiment is that contrary to the
compiler optimization communities
conventional wisdom grew prefetching is
actually better than software pipeline
profession this is because group
reversing has a simple implementation to
deal with the hash code complexity hi
join called complexities and this leads
to lower overhead so in a second step
exploit the two paths structure of hydro
an algorithm basically we have inspected
data almost for free during the i/o
partitioning phase and then we can use
this information for optimizing the
joint phase of the algorithm in two ways
first we can directly accelerate a cache
friendly a new cache finally join faze
algorithm called cash stationary join
and then based on the information about
the data we can choose the suit most
suitable algorithms to join face for
example we consider the situations where
the two implementation
and nearly sorted or there are a lot of
duplicate cheese in the invitations so
the idea behind the cash stationary join
phase is is that the eye opening phase
can by using a special or index you can
approximately find out the matching
approximate matching relationship
between the two input tables and then
the cash stationary join faze can reduce
the number of cache misses are taking
advantage of this information and the
important thing is that it does this
without any additional copying so that's
that's why I called cash stationary and
the cash station enjoying phase combines
cash prefetching and local optimizations
to reduce the memory bandwidth
requirement this is important for shared
baths memo 24 solar systems and it's
also important for the new multi
threading the multi-core architectures
because they're the off-chip memory
boundaries is shared by all the threads
and course on a single dark and it's
very valuable resource so experiment
results through simulation show that
when there are eight or more cpus in a
shared model for service system we can
achieve are using cash stationary join
can achieve up to 1.4 x speed ups or
cash professionalism
so II related work for people's free
cash performance there are a couple of
proposals to increase the file out of
the one cache line size we pass we note
by restricting the layouts in /
sensitive people trees and by
compressing Keys actual he treats also
Joe and Ross proposed techniques for
improving the throughput of a large
number of searches in trees the basic
idea is to create a buffer recreated
buffers at the tree nodes to group all
the searches reaching the same tree
nodes in order to reuse the tree nodes
for multiple searches reduced as mrs.
and tied our proposed sensitive
concurrency control scheme place our
optimistic of course consult I believe I
believe that all these techniques are
complementary my screen and they can be
included in my scheme so Hankins and
patel studied the optimal no sizes while
considering TLB misses an instruction
costs in addition to cache misses and
they found that the optimal size can be
as large as 512 bytes which is multiple
cache miss no headlines so this results
coincides with our finding about the
wider nodes idea so how is our results
and domain described the technique
called micro indexing to improve the
search cache performance in a deep page
for this ultimate people tree the basic
idea is to place to keep an array of a
few cache lines at the beginning of the
page to index the rest of the keys in
the page the search casual phones can be
improved by searching this small index
first and then go to a narrowed range of
keys in the
age and lo menos are advocated that this
case should be broken down into cash
friendly units and this point out that a
challenge of doing this is to find a
organization that can strike the balance
between search performance in certain
performance storage utilization and
simplicity so I believe our fractal
protection people tree achieve these
goals graafian Larsen and presented a
survey on the techniques of improving
CPU cache performance for because trees
they discussed a number of techniques
such as key compression and I think
these techniques can be utilized in our
system in our scheme there is also
theoretical work on cache oblivious
people trees which proposes the
structure that can achieve the optimal
of search performance a team thought
clay regardless of the block size so for
for cash drawing cache performance
shadow atau proposed partitioning scheme
which is a similar technique to io
positioning the basic idea is to
recursively partition the inputs into
cache size the partitions reduce cache
misses and banks it all further extended
this idea to reduce the aisle or the TLB
thrashing and cash thrashing and but in
our experiment we show that because of
this partitioning step cash partitioning
techniques are at least fifty percent
worse than the cache profession
techniques and many go dao proposed
techniques to reduce the cost of integer
divisions for computing the hash
function they do this by using integers
shifts and bit operations I think their
scheme is complementary to our scheme
and we can improve their scheme in our
solution so in conclusion
traditional database systems cannot take
advantage of the the modern computer
architecture features the memory cache
gap is becoming the major performance
problem of the days database system so I
exploit cash prefetching supported by
most processors today for index
structures I propose novel prefetching
techniques for people trees and I
proposed a novel structure to optimize
both cash and disk performance for doing
operations I propose normal profession
techniques for hash joints and also
exploit the two paths structure of her
joints or better performance I believe
that my techniques will be more and more
important with the architecture trend so
for future work and not only want to
work on CPU cache performance and
exploit cash prefetching for other
algorithms and structures in database
systems and also one to exploit the
multi-threaded and multi-core
architectures in more popular today
basically the Pentium 4 in her painting
for machine already supports to Hardware
threads running on a single die and IBM
power 5 and many other procedures
support multiple cores on a single dad
actually this week inhale have announced
their new processor to support two cores
on a single dime so at first glance
currently this ad I looks like a
minimized multiprocessor system however
they have different properties than a
true multiprocessor system so data
sharing here is across the the on-chip
cash therefore to the sharing across
multiple threads model course on a
single die is has very low cost however
our main memory bandwidth is shared by
all the threads are all the course
they're from main memory accesses will
become more costly a natural question to
ask a very interesting question to ask
is just how to efficiently use this new
architecture
for the immune system thank you I'm glad
to answer more questions yes in your
simulations how much single users
information how would the effect of the
higher levels of cash naturally okay
let's see so actually in this search
performance I perform back to pack
searches and this already contains the
the warm-up factor here so basically
some part of the so at least the root of
the tree will already be in cash for the
later searches yes
yes
currently no okay so in the embedded
system world they actually can have a
scratch error in the cache and I just
write to the cash and that part of the
cash can be controlled by by the
software and I think the so I talked to
my advisor and the architectural world
in artificial world people are very
flexible to took new cash schemes they
really wants to maybe make some little
changes in their cash scheme to support
a better and faster application
especially database application so
another very profitable area to work in
is to just maybe study the changes of
some cash schemes in order to support
faster database operations
yes it is only on the software side
basically taking a bunch of the existing
hardware features
thank you